did you make a goal to participate in
dry january that's no booze for a month
well don't lose hope there's still time
to end the month strong got about a week
bianca holman is live with more better
late than never right to get started
bianca
of course and if you started but you
fell off the wagon now's your chance
this is your call to finish out the
month strong so no hard liquor no wine
no beer we want to make sure that you're
successful to end the month of dry
january so if you really think about it
we started drinking probably heavily
back in halloween then there was
thanksgiving christmas hanukkah kwanzaa
new years i mean we've been drinking for
two months straight socially with
everybody so going cold turkey on booze
for four weeks can be difficult and may
be a goal for many to make healthy
changes at the start of the year that
can ease many ailments
for a lot of people that do abstain from
alcohol for periods of time intermittent
times throughout the year they notice
benefits such as weight loss there's a
high caloric intake with our alcohol
consumption as well as improved
cognition just having that mental
capacity to improve their thinking
so morning console
reports dry january participation grew
19 percent with adults many who are
millennials so this is an increase from
last year where 13 said they would
participate so coming up in the next
half hour we're going to talk more about
tips on how to in your month strong some
support things that you can do if you
have a friend that's participating and
then also when to recognize if your
alcohol consumption
could be a substance abuse issue the
alcoholman live local now